ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata febbraio è il
mese dell'amore lo sappiamo tutti quanti
fra quattro giorni sarà san valentino e
voglio celebrare questa giornata
vestendomi di nero a lutto
scherzi a parte una delle cose
traumatiche di san valentino è quella di
fare un regalo alla propria dolce metà
potrebbe non essere proprio quello che
il vostro partner desidera più di ogni
altra cosa e quindi ho pensato perché
non link artiamo in maniera intelligente
perché non facciamo una sorpresa allo
stesso tempo e quindi perché non
facciamo una torta con dentro un regalo
ha senso ma voglio mettere un regalo in
una torta da morello
ora siamo ancora più fighi secondo gli
studi all'interno del nostro diciamo lab
creativo abbiamo scoperto che le cose
che piacciono di più su internet sono il
cibo i gattini e le [ __ ] ora non potevo
prendere un cucciolo di gattino anche
perché sarebbe stato comunque a me
spiace o nei confronti del povero
animale ma ho trovato un modo per
evitare sporcarmi ogni volta i vestiti
sono stanco di dover rimettere la
matrice di posta che finisco di girare e
allo stesso tempo portare qui un'astra
[ __ ] cosmica quindi partiamo subito
col procedimento perché oggi oltre che
imparare come infilare un regalo
all'interno di una torta impareremo
anche come fare il pan di spagna al
microonde perché non ho tempo per
mettere roba in forno sinceramente mi
devo sbrigare tutto questo amore per
questa festività cielo per fare il pan
di spagna avevano bisogno di farina
lievito per dolci burro uova zucchero 2
cucchiai d'acqua prendiamo una
è un recipiente che avevamo qui e
iniziamo con la farina ma è stato lavato
questo qui l'ultima volta nel 15 18
lo usano i militari come il netto ante
guerra 225 grammi di farina che dobbiamo
setacciare noi non ho sistemato il seta
chino cacchio se sei minuti con un sacco
di persone anche quando salgono però
innalza 327 del resto non è che ho
imparato che in cucina ha bisogno di
essere precisi si mangia senza andare un
periodo si cercava calanca alla cala
cala cala cala cala cala cala cupa te
sempre alla mediocrità c'e chi punta al
successo verrà sono deluso se siete già
che gli e filtro psi e dell'impronta
tedesca di chef villa grock ops sporcato
la mancanza 225 grammi di burro comunque
quando fa i dolci te rendi conto di
quanta roba the money ignoranza un bene
siete ignoranti 27 tolgo va beh va bene
andiamo a microonde o sempre un po di
problemi con questo micro muller
trenta secondi
la micron un po sciolto morbido
aggiungiamo il burro aggiungiamo 4 uova
parentesi vorrei ringraziare sugar danny
89 perché stiamo prendendo la sua
ricetta
figuriamoci se lo spedì fatah yo yo
curioso questo lasciamo alla parte
esistente uno degli idraulico dell'alba
prossima acqua no perché ogni poi
lievito vanigliato perché se ci tieni
tanto ce la metto la vanillina chef
mario vuole la vanillina e noi mettiamo
anche la vanillina contento ma lo
zucchero riso ce l'ho messo lo zucchero
ha messo prima 225 g
come sei entrato sapere se ormai
dobbiamo fare tutto a mano
usiamo l'olio di gomito che per me come
l'olio di palma visto qualcosa che
scappava vieni qui dicono che se ci
stanno comunque dei grumi di burro non è
un problema perché queste qui si
scioglieranno all'interno del neurone
però io tutta sta fiducia e non gliela
darei perché sotto il nome di burro
classica ogni volta dimesso le manie
realtà di colpo sembra qualcos'altro
il mio bel corpo sinuoso
basta tortiere minuscola questo qui e ci
dà dentro secondo me i pasticceri per
prevenire la crescita eccessiva
nell'auto portarci questo motivo una
cosa così avevo visto in questa cucina
molti optional che tra parentesi è di
mio cugino quindi ringraziamo dovrebbe
questa qui sarà il cuscino non la cucina
prevedo aspetta mette un po di colla qui
usato male lo fa così no ma sono nate
sono quali crea una mette dieci minuti
microonde come avevo fatto la scorsa
volta ad arrivare al di due no no no no
no no sarà quello aveva infatti insieme
facciamo partire
[Musica]
così come la io me ne lavo le mani doria
di ronde a puzzare scoreggia un'altra
dice quasi un volo è cresciuto questo
bambino cioè breve arriverà per
francesco e si penserà che i nostri che
hanno fatto faville
ma su tutto capo unico ma soprattutto
giusto una uno stuzzicadenti perfetto
visto dove va bene anche una cannuccia
dello stretto
un risultato che siamo così sconvolta
quando vedere le cose
caspita perché a miseria lavorare quindi
possiamo dire che questa è una scelta
che possono pare di sì dieci minuti al
microonde stato troppo spavaldo l'ho
detto devo dirlo in maniera più completa
microonde aria quando sentite motori si
capisce che il pan di spagna è quasi
pronto pinter salvatore pisano vicini
alla conclusione che è un po come quando
mai di corpo che è venuto bene
passiamo quindi a gli ingredienti per il
ripieno allora avremo bisogno di
philadelphia google zucchero a velo
un sito con sé è un regalo la parentesi
questo è un regalo che abbiamo scelto
accuratamente con dentro un paio di
orecchini in sé non diciamo prezzo non
diciamo il prezzo non scherza sono i
biglietti da visita della ragazza il mio
cugino che sta lavorando un progetto
molto figo di cui vorrei parlarvi più
avanti ma non so se il permesso ancora
perché è top secret
precisi setacciamo 300 g di zucchero a
velo
la casacca la casacca alla galanti o
sette anni non esiste un modo per note
presenti setaccio dai su mai visto nuovo
setaccio dai 300 g di zucchero a velo
non setaccio tutto 150 g di burro 5 125
g di philadelphia con un massimo di tre
per cento di grassi questo non è uno
sponsor ma stanno cercando di
risparmiare un po di calorie perchè
mangi e può e la scorza di un sito con e
propongo prima di di mescolare con la
paletta felice e poi ci aggiungiamo le
fruste che già mettiamo questa qua un
attimo in frigo a raffreddarsi e
iniziano a prendere le misure del pan di
spagna
cos'è un volo con le mani passiamo a
questo punto alla parte più difficile o
più divertente o più tragica ancora devo
capire che quella di infilare questo qui
all'interno della torta il quale fare
per prima cosa è proteggere il regalo
con una pellicola nello stretto chiuso
ok
prendete un tagliere sporco dategli una
pulita iniziamo ad incidere iniziamo
eliminare uno strato venete già meta
parco centrodentro allora lo piazzate
sopra e poi lo tirate fuori cercando di
far di mantenere la posizione sembrava
una cosa impossibile ora vediamo alcuna
quando vai a tagliare la torta no
secondo me a tagliare la torta semplice
tira ma che cavolo c'è qua e un po dura
appena tagliato 300 ma facciamo un
pochino di ordine prendiamo la
saldatrice incomincia un chiudere tutto
quanto la prima sembra fare è quella di
piazzare sui lati da crema che fungerà
un pochino da collante questi sono i
biglietti da visita e roberta un pochino
perido non credo che vorrei fare lo
stesso
chiudiamo e a questo punto proviamo a
fare una cosa che io non so fare ma che
mi improvviserò chiedo perdono a tutti i
pasticceri che mi stanno guardando la
casa se sbaglio qualcosa perché non ho
mai imparato
beh dai non sono un pasticcere ma ciò è
dignitoso per mettere sempre la speciale
permesso amore grazie a dio l'amore
quello è l'ingrediente migliore di
questa ricetta non cade grande assente
la mettiamo subito in frigo che si sta
sciogliendo
dai su
e arrivato il momento di decorare questo
ammasso di impedire fantasmino quindi
prendiamo delle fragole e iniziano a
tagliarle che è lacerata dalle fragole
prima dopo aver leccato
io poi non ce la faccia da ragazzino
sono mele cotogne rosso però vabbè
questa volta la casa con e avanza una
enrico
sto pensando di fare questo intanto però
se ti piace questa è la pasticceria
no attendendo quella torta bisogna
mandare in caciara capiva faccio uno sui
ricchio dai sumera più bello se facilità
faccio anche quello fu un fu era più
bello si e questo è il risultato della
nostra torta regalo compari spagna cotto
al microonde cioccolato di sì è vero
basta cesar barattolo vogliamo passare
un micro assaggio per la fragolina che
non ce la mettete dentro testa di due
piedi al posto di tematiche molto buona
non è male certo questo è vomitando
ragazzi questa era la mia torta per san
valentino fatemi sapere se volete
cimentarvi in una cosa simile anche se
un po meno sconsigli o qualora doveste
fare
taka temi su instagram ma fatemi sapere
se questa ricetta in qualche modo che è
tornato a te ti mando un abbraccio vi
invito come sempre iscriversi a questo
canale attivare le campanelle se volete
sapere però beh se volete essere un
gioco ma trincererà babele solite cose
si fanno su youtube e ci vediamo la
prossima domenica un'altra ricetta
ciao ciao